I'm here in Coeur d'Alene Idaho I
seriously hope this place is better than
the other shitholes I've stayed in oh my
god
look at that they say all publicity is
good publicity or the billboard that old
fashioned I'm not so sure you're [ __ ]
joking aren't you come on in Bed and
Breakfast
no the Adams family Roosevelt's cool
place looks grim from the outside hello
welcome to the Roosevelt good to see I
recognize that boy sure Gordon Ramsay
okay well good see my girl best chance a
day from school they are those came out
of the first grade classroom well look
you almost fit so we'll do a first
impression for the outside is almost
like walking a few apart oh it smells
like [ __ ] as well what is that is that
the dog Stewart oh boy I sure hope not
this is our dining room who's the chef
here I saw a billboard of a guy with the
most hideous hat on covered in trees and
like this 6-foot hat it's kind of grown
into a monkey as he mad French chef of
the Roosevelts cousin Portland is a
French name town you know so we must
cooks a fabulous food beware this outfit
now you'll see school photos down the
hallway here and these are of kids that
went to school here at the Roosevelt and
the ones with the arrows pointing at the
really cute adorable little boy that's
me of course because I went to school he
was my elementary school who wants to
live in their old school there's like
get Li detention that never ends the
guests get to hang out down here with
the dogs and watch TV you are kidding me
you can't smell those dogs oh yes I can
the dogs actually believe it or not
Gordon are one of the highlights here
now you're sounding deluded what's next
our little ballroom or our multi-purpose
room oh come on Rohan you're not
supposed to be in this room don't you
think this place - at least had some
form of makeover well sadly Gordon we
renovated this room four years ago this
is new stop now this room looks like it
was last decorated in 1908 not 2008 so
how much they spend on us fifty four
thousand fifty four thousand five four
not fifty four hundred fifty fourth hour
I know lovely huh
christ almighty and there's a generate
money no I can't believe anyone would
want to read in that space it's hideous
I'm dying to have a look upstairs
chun-hee worse it could get worse and
what's your occupancy across the year
probably around mid-20s 20% across the
board I'm amazed you find it so funny
this is your room okay what's with all
the paint is like someone threw a
strawberry milkshake all over the place
my room has two levels each as bad as
the other Oh everything looks like we're
in a time I mean it's so dated so my
room how much do you pay to say no 319
319 dollars bloody hell I'm speechless
[Laughter]
13 year-old deck off hundred ninety
dollars a night I'll show you something
fire away why do you think everything's
a big joke
because you're very critical I'm here
displays rights but what I don't
understand is how blase you are to the
situation I am going to give you the
truth and if you don't like that then
I'm out of it what do you want me to do
get angry and punch you you want to
punch me you know fellas maybe I do want
to punch you a little bit I can become
physically very very violent and have in
the past people get hurt
[Music]
John
jump you can't just walk away where you
going
[Music]